i've worked at the same company for my
entire career which is completely
unheard of it's been a fantastic
learning ground here at micron for me
over the years my career progressed
about six years ago i was asked to take
on the head job for hr and then this
last year i was promoted to chief people
officer one of my sources of inspiration
or at least thought leadership
are my professors from scp but now i
need to go and give back and make sure i
create
the space and the opportunity for others
to have that same experience
and invest in themselves and learn and
develop and grow so my team and i are
working diligently on making sure we're
finding innovative ways to actually keep
our communities educated and and really
democratize a lot of the learnings that
we offer inside of the company and make
them available to community members as
well there is a tremendous opportunity
for us to take our digital skills
curriculum and just make it available to
anyone who wants to take our curriculum
that will not only
certainly help them prepare for a career
at micron but frankly will help them
prepare
for any other career or help them just
succeed in life
you